watch Hessler has mostly influenced your
chess career and why this is very
difficult question I am saying many
times I don't have just one role model I
admire people for different skills and
this is definitely all world champions
and especially like I'm a mother have
two kids and some chess players women
who combine just their chess career and
still playing like competitive chess
this is uh Pia crumlin who is still very
strong in her age and Monica sojko who
had like three kids and managing like
her chess career and another is
who became a GM in very like late age
like for around 40 I think she became a
GM
um you know I studied games from a lot
of good players and I definitely did
spend time on games collections you know
from the world champions and I feel like
from probably someone like botfunik
um in his Games Collection and you know
just learning a lot of Concepts from him
um opening things you know strategic
things I would say probably probably him
it's where I got my appreciation for big
Center and Bishop hair and I wasn't
little kid
um
starting from aliochine I think to
casparo for car park no kramnik and then
all of them
during this time they were very popular
I think it was Anatoly karpov I really
like to check his games with my watch
when I was young so probably yeah
probably it's just half I'm a big fan of
Anatoly carpool and also Judith polka so
from my anger days I used to follow
their games and
their play has inspired me a lot
was the ones that I really loved their
games and their style
casually was looking their games to
learn how to play chess and so I would
call their names I think Vladimir
kramnik or during my childhood days I
used to see a lot of his games and I
think somewhere I really like his style
and maybe not game wise but Judith
Polgar has a lot of influence on me as a
women player to be doing well in the men
to beat the strong man and like to be
there so definitely these two I think
are have influenced me a lot I was a fan
of Bobby pictures games when I was young
uh also Michael Tau was my favorite
chess player so I guess they influenced
my
style of play well honestly speaking my
dad is a grand master and he used to be
professional like when I was very young
so he had the deepest impact on me from
everybody because he taught me and my
brother at the early age how to play and
of course he went with us to tournaments
and he had been my teacher up till 16
before I actually met other trainers I
wish I wish I had such a player you know
it's such an influencer Mentor in a way
because
when I was growing up I wasn't really
excited about Chess lines and like moves
and champions in a way I was excited
about the psychological part of a battle
and I was I like to
um to read chess books I mean from Jazz
Champions but not about chess moves or
openings or middle games nothing about
that but rather about psychological
preparation and about how games like uh
went and how they prepared and what went
wrong if they lost so I didn't have a
chess Mentor in a way and I feel that
I'm lacking this like information right
now because definitely like your
youngest years are the best in order to
consume and
be able to learn certain material but of
course it's never too late with the chat
book and what I'm trying to do right now
is to learn from those great chess
Champions and their games because well
you need to know history in order not to
make the same mistake in your own games
[Music]